welcome to this video playing garlic
garlic from the US let's see an Italian
game playing this was blue should be
seven for a change this is some a bit a
bit more interesting sometimes then the
Bishop c5 setups there are more pieces
left on the board in a way because after
Bishop c5 very Orton what gets in Bishop
e3 to trade hmm yeah King h8 is some
prep move 498 @ f 5 which is an
interesting setup that I have played a
number of times against this which is
not sure about this particular move on
st for now as possible but okay it's
probably still a playable playable set
up okay so he's not playing t form hmm
okay f5 is the idea anyway so I better
get going okay well now I'm threatening
Bishop g4 this is a really annoying pin
so yeah he needed to do something
against it um yeah to g6 proliant um to
threaten Bishop h5 again again going for
the pin
yes I think already should be quite okay
for black shouldn't determine the rook
is open or he's totally ignoring it
interesting maybe 93 wasn't really
designed to avoid the pendant it wasn't
mostly a coincidence that he had done
something against it hmm ok so i will be
able to give him this double pones hmm
yeah Knight takes is not without its
points night maybe have a good root over
g 6 ok maybe not bad and Queen to d7 I
mean I already can adjust to the
situation after the capture here so here
ok then now then there's 95 probably so
I'm going to take and now Queen d7 was
my idea Queen to h3 and night to g6
yeah that should be very nice really
yeah he's got the total Bishop out two
bishops against two nights but well it's
all about checkmate this game and with
this bad King position hmm i don't think
that this can be any good for wine okay
so nigh g6 and Queen h3 or is there
something better
now it should be at least fine um move
like h5 is probably answered by a form
hmm yeah that's not so attractive
I also has assured d5 at some point
I wonder if I should really just grab
the porn i mean i'm not i'm probably not
getting a meeting attack here I don't
think so he's going to play King h1n
turn and the rock g1 so I'm just trying
to get the pawn yeah but I thought this
would be a bit slow with 97 and so on I
came modest first or night f4 here also
now has some pointers ok I'm spending
too much time one hour one hour would be
nice and what made 35 seconds and I came
time to have to speed up
yeah that's really the number one
violation of good time management rules
that I'm committing all the time when I
see like three good moves and I try to
even in those games because I'm I'm
doing this this comentary I'm sort of
going through my thoughts and trying to
figure out what is the best move and
it's of course just the right policy in
terms of getting the best results to
just play one of the good moves which is
what I actually do in in over the bought
blitz I'm in over the bot blitz I don't
get into time trouble at all usually I'm
usually the one having more time sounds
a bit strange if you watch my videos but
that's really the case so we just sort
of happening as I go along i can do that
or this also good and then there's like
15 seconds burned or 20 seconds burned
when I could easily have played one of
the good moves in a number of seconds
okay you are here i thought that i will
get to be too after the capture and if
you hadn't captured i would just have
one f 3 so this looks like very nice and
if i get to be too it's a very nice
replacement also attacking on f2 he has
no real way also need to take their
ceilings oh that's early I mean okay
what is probably lost but some still a
bit early and many good ideas i can pick
up pawns I can play like this rook to d2
somehow it is not
draw the arrow I don't know why I'm
strange and i also have ideas like oh
that's actually very strong like d5 i
cannot wait i have ideas like d5 and
rugby 62 h 6 that's really strong yeah
the computers on minus 6y a minus 6
that's quite a lot well I thought okay I
should win the game but I wasn't like
thinking it is minus 6 but that's really
very strong the same maneuver getting to
age two and at the same time sort of
yeah attacking the bishop and it can
rarely it can barely save itself this
piece yeah I'm very strong yeah the
problem was that he had simply ignored
this Bishop h5 idea I thought that with
night III here he would have addressed
this but you own hero only wanted to
transfer the night in the middle of the
board it seems now after Bishop age five
Black is already a quite clearly better
because you don't have any compensation
for the for the bed structure and this
is not helping at all i guess but okay
it's very tough to to give white some
advice as some it is already so tricky
or the computer is some giving a very
interesting mafia rook takes a three
yeah not bad not bad now Queen d7
intending to get this typical mating
pattern queen on h3 bishop on f3 yeah
that's that's probably even better than
what I did this kind of position look at
this
this is probably a pretty pretty
dangerous mating attack this Bishop
won't be three is completely out of
defensive out of defence of ideas it
cannot help in any way and I'm getting
to f3 and that's very strong really okay
this this was not bad at all but it
wasn't as decisive GM oh I'm okay yeah I
briefly thought about that the comp is
giving this yeah that's very strong
actually he has a hard time to prevent
h4 I was always a bit skeptical about
the idea because some yeah this this
Queen age five would be a check made you
had this bishop okay this doesn't make
any sense i just want to show you my
idea because i can take a here but um
something like that some checkmate to be
avoided this is why i didn't think about
age five much like here here age five he
has this this idea and the Queen age
five is checkmate I can I can play
something like that but it seems
unnecessarily complicated to me mmhmm
yeah I think I'm what I did was probably
not sorry in the absolutely best way to
play but it was certainly enough to win
the game at the end alright thanks for
watching